the pancho has been training for three
years his goal to play for india but
fifa's band may change that actually the
main dream is that world cup but because
of the world cup is
organized by fifa so we can't play
because of the fifa band but
i hope government will do something and
uplift the band but
but till then we can play national
football like isl and all that leaks
fifa has suspended the federation that
manages football in india trouble began
when its former president stayed on
after his tenure ended the supreme court
replaced him and appointed a committee
to manage the football body
fifa has called it undue influence from
third parties which constitutes a
serious violation of its statutes fifa
says it will reverse the ban if the
committee is disbanded and control is
handed back to the federation the
supreme court is hearing the matter and
has asked the government to get involved
new delhi's biggest priority is
retaining hosting rights
the under 17 women's world cup is
scheduled to take place in october
indian players have also been banned
from international matches
when gokulam kerala arrived in
uzbekistan for the asian women's club
championship they were told they
couldn't play
it is very humiliating for the entire
footballing fraternity of india
and this is not the way we should go
ahead
the ban has prompted concerns about the
future of the game in india
obviously if you're not recognized in a
sport why would anybody want to play the
sport that's common sense right so
that is a huge deterrent of it has led
to a lot of aspirants giving up sport
not taking up sport uh because there
were other challenges in life and other
challenges in india too so it has meant
that has been for the past two years
they've been it's been a problem
youth competitions could not be held
because there were vaccine issues etc so
anywhere the sport was reeling
the government says it's talking to fifa
to find a solution
players and fans are watching closely
hoping
india will be back in action soon
al jazeera new delhi